you know the way I think about attention
is really as a problem of routing
routing signals so actually we know a
lot about how signals come in through
your sensory apparatus through your ears
and your eyes we know an awful lot about
how the retina works how the cochlea
works we understand how the signals
travel up and eventually they percolate
up to the cortex in the case of sound
they percolate up to the auditory cortex
and we know a lot about a fair amount
about how they look once they get there
and after that we kind of lose track of
them and we can't really pick up the
signal until where they're coming out
the other end we know a lot about
movement we understand awful lot about
what happens when a nerve impulse gets
to a muscle and how muscles contract
that's been pretty well understood for
50 years or something you're more than
that so where we really lose track of
them is when they enter into the early
parts of the sensory cortex and when
they're we pick them up again sort of on
the on the other side and so attention
is one of the ways in which signals can
find their destination if you like so
think about it in terms of a really
specific problem imagine that I ask you
to raise your right hand when I say go
okay so I say go you raise your right
hand
go raise your right hand now let's
change it and I say go raise your left
hand go raise your left hand so somehow
the same signal coming in through your
ear is producing different activity at
the other end somehow the signal on the
sensory side had to be routed to either
the muscles of your right hand or the
muscles of your left hand now attention
is a special case of that kind of
general routing problem that the brain
faces all the time because when you
attend to let's say your sounds rather
than your visual input or when you
attend to one particular auditory input
out of many what you're doing is you're
you're selecting some subset of the
inputs in this case coming in
to your ears and and subjecting them to
further processing and you're you're
taking those signals and routing them
downstream and doing stuff with them how
that routing happens that's the aspect
of attention that my lab focuses on so
so the basic setup for the problem that
I'm interested in is this imagine that
you're at a cocktail party there are a
bunch of conversations going on and
you're talking to someone but there's
all this distracting stuff going on the
sidelines you can make a choice you can
either focus on the person you're
talking to and ignore the rest or as
often happens you find that the
conversation that you're engaged in is
not as interesting and oh really summer
okay and you start focusing in on this
conversation on the right your ability
to focus in on this conversation while
ignoring that conversation that is sort
of the challenge understanding how we do
that is the challenge of my research and
that problem actually has two separate
aspects so there's one aspect of that
problem that is really a problem of
computation it's it's a problem that is
a challenge to basically any computer
namely we have a whole bunch of
different sounds and from a bunch of
different sources and they're
superimposed at the level of the ears
and somehow they're they're added
together and to us it's typically pretty
effortless for us to separate out those
different threads of the conversation
but actually that's a surprisingly
difficult task so computers maybe 10
years ago already we're getting pretty
good at doing speech recognition and in
controlled situations in quiet rooms
computers were actually pretty good at
recognizing even random speakers but
when people actually started deploying
these in real-world settings where
there's traffic noise and whatnot the
computer algorithms broke down
completely and it was sort of surprising
at first because that's the aspect that
we as humans seem to have not much
trouble with at all so the the ability
to take
apart the different components of an
auditory scene that's what we've evolved
for hundreds of millions of years to do
really well so that's one aspect of
attention there's almost this sort of
aspect of it that happens before we're
even aware of it where the auditory
scene is broken down into the components
the other aspect which is the one that
we're sort of more consciously aware of
is the one where out of the many
components of this conversation we are
of this auditory scene we select one and
that's the one we focus in on right so
at this hypothetical cocktail party we
have the choice of focusing on either
the conversation we're engaged in or
this one or that one